[Music]
on this sunday night a moment of truth
for the planet
what's at stake at the cop26 climate
summit if glasgow fails
then the whole thing fails why g20
countries are already being criticized
global news on the ground in afghanistan
the struggle to help afghans caught in a
spiraling humanitarian crisis alberta's
push for its own police force while the
province is considering replacing the
rcmp and taking the field by storm the
lines are laser straight the circles are
perfect the little robot painting a fine
line at the university of british
[Music]
columbia global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with what's being called the
world's last best hope to come together
to prevent a climate disaster
that was the opening gavel in glasgow
scotland the high stakes cop 26 summit
is now officially underway for the next
two weeks negotiators will work with
roughly 200 countries to try to hammer
out more aggressive climate commitments
there are already signs of how difficult
those negotiations will be ahead of the
summit g20 leaders met in rome there
were hopes the block would go into
glasgow with a solid climate action plan
but as michael couture reports in
tonight's top story the meeting ended
with few concrete commitments
even the first major in-person meeting
in two years couldn't bring world
leaders closer together on the issue of
climate change after a traditional coin
toss into the trevi fountain which local
lore says will bring you back to rome
the leaders looked for ways forward on
more ambitious ways to tackle climate
change they got a royal reminder of the
urgency quite literally it is the last
chance saloon
we must now translate fine words into
still finer actions but that not so
subtle nudge still wasn't enough in the
final communique g20 leaders agreed to
softer language on reaching net zero
emissions setting a target of quote by
or around mid-century canada's pledge is
to be carbon neutral by 2050 and prime
minister justin trudeau wishes others
would follow suit there's no question
that canada and along with a number of
other countries would have liked
stronger language and stronger
commitments on the fight against climate
change than others but we did make
significant
significant progress on recognizing 1.5
degrees is the ambition we need to share
1.5 degrees celsius is the ceiling on
global temperature increases compared to
pre-industrial level coal was also
contentious g20 leaders did agree to end
public financing of coal-fired power
generation abroad but there are no
targets to phase out coal domestically
it's widely seen as a nod to countries
like china and india who still depend on
coal as a primary energy source but
trudeau pointed out some coal dependent
countries are facing energy challenges
as they come out of the pandemic they're
basically saying look we'll want to do
less we want to do less but we can't
if we want to keep our economies running
we need to be phasing out coal rapidly
it needs to happen not only by removing
financial support for new power plants
but actually phasing out the ones that
are currently in operation despite the
disappointment being felt here at the
g20 prime minister trudeau said
countries need to make sure ambition
continually scales up especially as he
and other world leaders now head to
glasgow for the u.n climate change
conference
robin michael couture in rome thanks
mike
part of the canadian delegation headed
to glasgow is new environment minister
stephen gilbeau while on route the
former greenpeace activist shared this
photo this will be his 19th cop summit
but his first representing the
government ahead of the first full day
of talks our europe bureau chief crystal
comancing reports on what's at stake and
what to watch for
the scene in glasgow is set for world
leaders the looming question will they
come with decisive aggressive plans to
protect our planet if we don't act
now
it will be too late
and we've been saying that for a long
time sir david attenborough dedicated
his life to understanding and sharing
the natural world he warns there's no
more time to kick the future of the
planet down the road we've said well in
the next 10 years or something i think
our 10 years time that's a couple of
budgets away and that you know
politicians won't do things we have to
do it now
the climate and political commitments
have been discussed for years literally
at cop 21 in paris 196 nations signed on
to the paris climate agreement the
legally binding initiative saw countries
commit to limit global warming to below
two degrees compared to pre-industrial
levels while reducing greenhouse gases
now at cop 26 nations are supposed to
share what they've been doing and
present their next steps catherine
mckinney is a former canadian
environment minister turned full-time
climate advocate transitions aren't
linear and they're not perfect and so
you know you can't immediately wave a
magic wand and say
you know we're getting rid of oil and
gas people are used we use oily gas
everyone is using oil and gas but we do
need to transition time to transition is
butting up against the realities of
climate change 2020 was the worst year
on record for the accumulation of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
according to the world meteorological
organization
carbon dioxide levels rose more than the
10-year average this despite the global
shutdown during the pandemic
noaa the national center for
environmental information says 2020 was
the second warmest year for combined
land and ocean temperatures and the
warmest for land temperatures
alok sharma is the uk's cop 26 president
if temperatures continue to rise we will
step through a series of one-way doors
and the end destination of which is
climate catastrophe
people around the world are experiencing
the devastating effects of a warming
planet intense storms fires droughts
even infestations
stopping these events will take money
particularly if poorer nations are to be
expected to move away from fossil fuels
fulfilling the 100 billion dollar pledge
has been delayed until 2023 but climate
financing is still a key discussion
point there are also outstanding issues
in the paris rule book that must be
settled dealing with carbon markets and
offsetting
the stakes are high and calls for
concrete action will be front and center
during the two-week summit
now for anyone trying to get to cop 26
today from the south it was virtually
impossible a storm system in the area
caused rolling delays and cancellation
starting first thing this morning at
houston station in london it was so
packed with stranded travelers that you
really couldn't step anywhere without
hitting someone and the entrance gates
were closed people were told to go home
to try to travel tomorrow there were
issues with signals on the lines and
blocked tracks for anyone who did try to
make it out they were eventually turned
around and delayed that included the
environment minister zach goldsmith
throw it back to you robin crystal
goodmansing in milton keynes england
turning to the pandemic after nearly
three weeks supporting an overwhelmed
critical care unit in edmonton nine
nurses from the canadian military are
going home the canadian armed forces has
had sent the nurses from ontario and
nova scotia to the royal alexandra
hospital jason kenney's government
requested federal help in late september
when a fourth wave surged the spread of
coven 19 has declined slightly in
alberta but of the 180 patients in icu
86
are unvaccinated or only partially
vaccinated
in the u.s the rates of new coven-19
infections and hospitalizations are
dropping but with the upcoming holidays
there are concerns there could be
another surge only 58 of americans are
fully vaccinated and across the country
vaccine mandates are leading to walkouts
and protests as jennifer johnson reports
the biden administration and local
lawmakers aren't backing down
and just relax u.s vice president kamala
harris received her cobia 19 booster
shot while strongly urging all americans
to get vaccinated about 30 percent of
the u.s adult population still has not
gotten a single shot the vaccines are
free
they are safe
and they will save your life
[Applause]
across the country vaccine mandates are
leading to angry protests all new york
city public workers are required to be
vaccinated by monday garbage is piling
up as sanitation workers call in sick
hundreds of police officers and
firefighters are still refusing to
comply new york city is going to come to
a crisis on monday morning response
times are going to go through the roof
cover 19 has been the leading cause of
death for america's law enforcement
officers since the pandemic began
millions of federal workers are also
facing a november 22nd vaccine deadline
as the biden administration fights to
end this pandemic young children will be
vaccinated next after pfizer received
emergency fda approval to immunize kids
ages 5 to 11. shots could begin early
this week we certainly hope that as
people see
children getting vaccinated and being
protected and being able to participate
in activities without concern
that more and more people will get their
kids vaccinated proof of vaccination
will be required by most businesses in
los angeles starting thursday leading to
even more controversy
i'm in the hospitality business i want
to make people feel good and not bad new
coven 19 infection rates and
hospitalizations are finally trending
down in the u.s but health experts are
concerned the virus could start
spreading again after the holiday season
we are now heading in the right
direction and but with cases still high
we must remain vigilant heading into the
colder drier winter months that's why
the push is on to get millions more
vaccinated but it's been a tough sell
even though the virus has killed almost
750 000 americans
jennifer johnson global news washington
actor alec baldwin is speaking publicly
about the shooting death of
cinematographer helena hutchins on the
set of the movie rust he made the
remarks to tabloid media
we were a very very
you know well-oiled crew shooting a film
together and then this horrible event
happened there are incidental accidents
on film sets
from time to time but nothing like this
this is a one in a trillion episodes
baldwin says he can't talk about the
ongoing investigation though he adds he
supports efforts to limit the use of
firearms on film sets during a rehearsal
earlier this month the star fired a prop
gun that contained a live round despite
being told it was safe
coming up the report into replacing the
rcmp in alberta
passengers onboard a tokyo train were
forced to run for their lives some even
jumping from windows to escape a
stabbing spree a man wielding a knife
attacked several passengers and set a
fire on board at least 17 people were
hurt one person was critically injured a
24 year old man was arrested and remains
in custody
in alberta there's a government study
underway about replacing the royal
canadian mounted police with a
provincial police force it's a
controversial concept and could be
costly and the union representing
mounties isn't thrilled about the idea
as david aiken explains such a move
could have national ramifications
in eight provinces three territories and
more than 150 municipalities across the
country it is the mounties who hand out
speeding tickets and force bylaws and
track down thieves thugs and drug
dealers but alberta wants to say goodbye
to the red surge and establish its own
provincial force a mary in-alberta
solution that could be both more
efficient
cost effective
and more responsive to the challenges of
policing in rural communities
and the particular needs of their
residents the union representing rcmp
members disagrees i would think that the
commanding officer of alberta or any
commanding officer of the rcmp who does
contract policing would probably be
somewhat offended by that indeed mayors
of some alberta towns have already said
they would get less police at a higher
cost if they made the switch a decision
in alberta in any event is likely years
away but in the meantime the debate
alone could hasten changes within the
rcmp first can the rcmp be changed in a
way that would make it
much more relevant much more humane in
the use of force and so forth still mps
from all parties on a house of commons
committee recommended in june that the
rcmp should get out of the business of
contract policing
but if the trudeau government agrees
with that idea well it would find
opposition canadians that are serviced
by the rcmp
in a contract policing capacity show 75
or more consistently time and time and
time again that they are satisfied with
the services they received by their
contract policing partner there's now a
new minister in charge of the rcmp he's
toronto mp marco mendicino his office is
not responding to the alberta report but
the issue is almost certain to reach his
desk in this new parliament david aiken
global news ottawa
still ahead afghanistan's humanitarian
crisis while those trapped there are
losing hope that canada will help
since 2001 canada has provided 3.6
billion dollars in development
assistance to afghanistan but that
foreign aid is largely frozen with the
taliban controlling the country and
those afghans who help canada run
development programs and promote women's
rights say they're now being targeted by
the militant group jeff semple reports
from kabul
afghanistan is staring into a
humanitarian crisis these ten cities are
popping up across the capital after
seven hundred thousand afghans were
forced to flee their homes last summer
during fighting with the taliban now
living without food health care or
hopeless
we're stuck here in these tents and the
winter is coming he says we need help
mohamed ibrahimi is trying to answer
that call
he works for a canadian organization
here interviewing displaced afghans to
determine how best to respond
multiple families here are sharing a
single tent including this 15 day old
baby they were living in a condition
which is not a humanitarian the
situation is very bad
ibrahimi's organization called canadian
women for women in afghanistan has
received approval for funding from
ottawa to buy badly needed blankets and
food but since the taliban took over the
country's banking system and foreign aid
are effectively frozen how we can
continue work
given that the canadian government is
not accepting taliban mohammed faheed
tahiri runs another afghan ngo which is
also partly funded by the canadian
government between the international
community and the taliban it is the
people which suffers
it is the people of afghanistan that are
punished he says the same organizations
scrambling to respond to the
humanitarian situation are also dealing
with their own crises his group which
focuses primarily on women's rights
is no longer allowed to have women
workers in its office and almost all of
his staff are trying to escape the
country
these canadian-funded groups
particularly those promoting women's
rights now fear they could be targeted
by the taliban there are many threats to
us because we are not feeling safe
afghans who worked for canadian ngos are
eligible to come to canada as refugees
we met this afghan former ngo worker in
pakistan enroute to canada he received a
canadian visa and escaped the country
with his family including his daughter
and his niece
[Music]
born just days after crossing the border
she is lucky and going to canada soon
and she will have a perfect life here
but the canadian government appears to
have recently quietly changed the rules
for refugee eligibility around october
14th the government's website switched
from allowing human rights workers who
are in afghanistan to apply to only
those who are already outside of
afghanistan canada is taking the easy
route
it is easy to process people that are
outside of afghanistan trying to process
people in a war zone and in hiding
that's not an easy thing to do
but for those still in afghanistan there
are few safe routes out ibrahimi is
scrambling to help the homeless while
also worrying about his own family
two young children and his wife an
engineer who was completing her mba when
the taliban took over she can no longer
study or work we don't know about our
future we have dark future
ibrahimi and his colleagues have applied
to go to canada but most haven't
received a response
they're still scared that we may be
targeted maybe
we may be questioned we may be
so we need to get out of here but for
now he can't leave and he also can't
stay and work in the absence of canadian
funding
like the afghans he supports left in
limbo as canada and its allies decide if
and how to deal with taliban controlled
afghanistan jeff semple global news
kabul
up next auto alignment the tiny robot
changing the game for prepping the game
painting the lines on a football field
isn't as exciting as the actual game but
it can take a day of painstaking
guesswork yet that's no problem for one
robot at the university of british
columbia it can do all that in just an
hour christa dow looks at the machine
painting a promising career ahead of a
busy sports season
he is a cherished member of the ubc
athletics and recreation department nice
and quiet to work with
doesn't complain
this is robbie the robot a lions keeper
some say is in a league of his own it
takes all the guess work out the lines
are laser straight the circles are
perfect
robbie can do what his human colleagues
do only faster and more consistent the
lines are in the same place every time i
can paint the field probably in about an
hour and a half instead of
four or five hours manually despite
robbie's ability and automation he still
requires constant supervision from his
superior
i treat him like a staff member
he treats me like a staff member
sometimes we don't get along so well but
at the end of the day we get the job
done and we both walk away happy
he is among the first of his kind in
canada arriving here three years ago
from a danish company called turf tank
he cost about 30 to 40 thousand dollars
purchased through a partnership between
ubc and the whitecaps soccer team so the
field is already laid out through gps
technology robbie can paint any outdoor
field in any configuration he runs off a
gps so there's a base station that
receives satellite
information so between those two points
he knows exactly where he is the
precision something the white caps
coaching team relies on what we're
looking for is a very technical side
because our coaches want different
colored lines different specs every day
or every week he does his job
to date robbie is responsible for all
the outdoor grass and turf fields giving
it 110 percent
rain or shine
krista dow global news
and that is global national for this
halloween night i'm robin gill
[Music]
trick-or-treating is not just for kids
at least at the toronto zoo where some
furry friends and some not so furry ones
enjoyed their own jack-o'-lanterns thank
you for watching have a great night
[Music]